are you ready to Ace your next technical
programming interview in this video
Keith Galley conducts a mock full-length
real-world coding technical interview
with Kylie Ying for a software
engineering role learn how to use object
oriented programming and dynamic
programming to solve questions and get
the job you want
most people will probably agree that one
of the worst Parts about finding a job
as a software engineer is the technical
interview during these programming
related interviews the interviewer will
expect you to work to a solution
optimize it and write code or pseudocode
on the spot the reasoning Behind these
interviews is that they will help the
interviewer understand your ability to
understand the problem ask questions go
deeper and optimize the solution how
much do you understand data structures
and algorithms and ultimately what is
your coding level and what is your
coding ability today I paired up with a
good friend of mine Keith Galley who has
a data science focused YouTube channel
and he is going to be mock interviewing
me so this interview might look like
what a real software engineering
interview looks like I don't know what
question he's going to ask so it's going
to be as much of a surprise to me as it
is to you and I will be coating on the
spot so
here we go
welcome
to the interview how are you doing today
I'm good how are you I'm doing pretty
well
um we're gonna probably just jump right
into this interview I'm just curious are
you familiar with coderpad because
that's what we're going to be using
throughout I think it might be easiest
to kind of share code
yeah
cool all right so we're going to kind of
just jump right into the the problem so
for the purpose of this problem and let
me share I just want to make sure you
can access this coder link so I'm going
to share this and I recommend maybe
sharing your screen or I guess we also
can just work off of this so I should be
able to see here what you typed in
I open the chat I can click on this link
and it'll take me to the coder pad my
name is Kylie and I will enter and so I
can see that you're in this coder PAD as
well and then here I am yeah and just to
make sure that you're comfortable here
you want to just run like a couple
simple lines of code you can try just
running this print hello world
if you want yeah so if I run this
it'll say that I ran a line of python it
prints out hello world so
I think it works perfect okay so let's
uh kind of jump into the problem so just
to give you some context we're going to
start with about 20 minutes of design
object-oriented design however you want
to design this code and then we'll spend
probably the last 20 minutes working on
more of an algorithms question so that
gives you just a little bit of a scope
uh you don't necessarily have to
accomplish everything you know I know
that we have limited time
but to kind of give you the context of
the problem
imagine that where
designing a book system so an online
Cloud reading application
and you can pretty much imagine that
we're building a product that is similar
to an Amazon Kindle
but specifically for short stories so
we're kind of in our own Niche they
might be Indie stories they might not be
you know found anywhere else people
could add their own stories
um and basically what we want to do to
start this problem off is that we need
help designing the actual
application we needed help designing the
code that could Implement an online
Cloud reading application and there's a
couple things that we're looking for and
this is very open-ended you can
implement this how you want but a few
things and I'll paste these into the
coder pad that we're looking for
I'll just paste it below
um oh yeah okay
you can fix this up
and I'll delete that Top Line
okay so a few things that you're looking
for users have a library of books that
they can add to or remove from users can
set a book from their Library as active
um the reading application remembers
where a user left off in a given book
and the reading application only
displays a page of text at a time in the
app in the active book
exactly
awesome
um so
so let's see
essentially what we want to do is create
a library where users can interact with
this Library they can look at a book and
set it as active and then
this application will also just remember
where they left off and display whatever
page that they're currently looking at
in the active book
is that correct correct correct
okay and then more specifically do you
want me to kind of give like a high
level implementation or
um how do you want me to start this
so I really want to just think about you
know what components would be important
this is I would say an object-oriented
design question so I'm just thinking
about how you would think about
structuring uh I guess the base of a
program like this so obviously we're not
going to build this full application but
I'm really curious about how you're
structuring that kind of that core
structure that core um
Foundation
right so let me make this uh smaller
over on this end so people can see all
this
and let's type up some more notes so uh
the things that jump out to me are that
you need to be able to remember all
books so if I type this
we need to have all books in the library
and we need to
um remember active book and then we want
to remember page
uh
remember page I guess last pages in all
books
and then
we want to
display
a page in active book Okay so
um by this all books in the library is
that more so
I guess how are we representing these
books are we are they just like strings
do they have a page number and then the
string of text how is that formatted is
it like HTML I think it's up to you how
you want to
um store the books within like this
programming structure so you can kind of
decide what makes sense
for that
I think the important things is the
actual text of the book as well as the
title of the book
okay okay and and you can implement the
uh the details of like the pages and all
of that yeah
yeah okay so I think that there's two
things that jump out to me here right
it's we need one class
we want one class representing
a book and then we want another class
perhaps representing a library so a
collection of books and so in this uh
book specifically you just mentioned
that we want the title as well as the
like pages in the book yep
or like I could rename that the content
yep exactly um in the book and then for
the library we have a collection of
books and then I would also argue that
this page uh or sorry that whatever the
active book is would would be at the
library level because
um because we just want to toggle which
one is active amongst this entire group
right yeah and then actually so this
last page in the book what I want I
think I'm gonna put that under the book
because it's book specific so I think it
would make sense for every single book
to just remember the last page so
um
user looked at
okay so I like how this is represented
and then I think uh kind of diving more
so into the implementation I think for
the title A String would make sense here
because
I mean a title is just a string yeah
um the pages and the content in the book
so the things here are the pages are
ordered right when you go through a book
They're ordered and there's a specific
amount of content per page and so I
think something that would make sense
for this is just a list because I think
a list is ordered it's a collection of
items and
um
and we can't I mean I think like a set
you would lose the ordering a dictionary
you would lose the ordering and you
would also over complicate things a
little bit you could have the page
numbers as the keys but then
um but then a list would also do the
same thing but kind of in a more elegant
manner
and then finally
uh a tuple okay you could also have a
tuple but
um I don't think there's a reason to use
like a tuple over a list in this
specific example yep or like vice versa
like I I think that you could choose
from either one
so I think here I'm just gonna use a
list of
um
I guess strings
which represent per page
so like each string represents
whatever's on an entire page
and then the last page that the user
looked at this would just be some
integer and this would be an index into
this list of strings so
I would have to remember that this you
know
there might be an off by one error here
um because in Python we start at zero
but like naturally when we're reading a
book we might start at one yep
now for this library for this collection
of books okay well so for this active
book
um I you could either use a Boolean
where you set one book to active and the
rest to inactive but I think that that
would be kind of excessive because every
single time we toggle a book as active
we have to toggle everything else as
inactive right
you can't have two active books yeah
yeah okay yeah that makes sense okay so
then I think in that case instead what I
would rather do is have some sort of
um
a string or some sort of like an ID
matching system where we have like one
um variable that's set to the active
book and that might be the title or the
ID of a certain book in the library so
maybe maybe we can just add ID here
um and maybe I can make that also a
string or an integer or something yep
and I'm going to add a question mark to
kind of just say like maybe we could
Implement that but I'm not sure if we'd
want to right now
um
so this would correspond
to ID
so uh
this would just be some variable
and then this collection of books
so
I guess like when we display this page
in an active book
um
I actually so I think that this week
this might have an advantage being like
some sort of a lookup table because we
have
a certain sense of an ID right and I
think what could make sense here is
having the ID correspond to the book
object that we Define up here so yeah
this could be a book object right and so
um we don't really need this idea I
think that if all the titles are unique
then then we don't need this ID we can
just we can just use the titles as the
IDS uh but in some cases in the real
world not all titles are unique and so
that's what an ID might might come in
handy
um and so I'll leave that like
what are our assumptions here can we
assume that the titles are unique or
should I be using this ID structure I
think I like the ID structure because
yeah we're not necessarily going to know
that everything's unique so I think this
is a little bit more robust
okay awesome so I think
um this representation looks good to me
so I'm just going to go through uh the
requirements again just to make sure
that I've covered all my bases so here I
want all books
um
okay so I want a library books that I
can add to or remove from and so here I
have a library and anytime I want to add
to this Library I can just add an ID I
can add the book If I want to remove
um from the from the library then I can
just simply delete the key item pair
or the key whatever pair
key value pair
um I can set a book from their Library
as active and so here I have this active
book and we could always say like if
there is no active book then we set this
To None or something like that
um the reading application remembers
where a user left off so we have that
here right the last page that the user
looked at and not just in the active
book
and then
um displaying one page of text at a time
in the active book so we have the active
book we can get the book object from
that and then we can go to the page that
the user last looked at by indexing this
value into this list so I think we've
covered all the bases here cool
um let's do a couple things
I guess I think as a starting point and
this doesn't have to get too crazy but I
would love to just see some you know
python pseudocode or even some python
kind of code just to like maybe flesh
out one of these classes I just want to
yeah uh you know look at that a little
bit and how you would actually start
writing this code
yeah sure so so for example here I let's
start with the book
um and when we define a class let's
initialize this
so when we initialize a book we
definitely should pass in the title and
then
um the content right I'm assuming that
when we add a book these things have to
be given to us and then
I'm assuming that when we add a book we
don't have a last page that the user has
looked at is that an okay assumption
yeah I like that assumption
okay
so we can set the title of this book
just equal to whatever the title is
uh the content of this book and I'm
going to assume that these are given to
us in the formatting that we want so the
title is a string and the content is a
list of strings that correspond to the
pages
um
and I'm gonna create a variable last
page and I'm going to set that equal to
just zero
I could also probably set it equal to
negative one or something but I think
zero makes sense because that would be
the beginning right yep and
um and then we need to come up with some
sort of an ID so
typically maybe we would have some sort
of function that takes in the title and
the content or maybe the author or
something and like returns a unique ID
um
but I think maybe something that we can
do here just very simply is uh have some
sort of counter in the library and then
every single time we like at add a new
book we can just associate that counter
with that book and so then we know that
they're all unique and
um
and they all have their own IDs would
that make sense yeah that that makes
sense
okay so then I would have to pass in the
ID
um
yeah and so what I'm actually going to
do is self.id equals ID
uh and then
yeah and so then uh for example we might
want like a display page
right in this book and so
for that then we just want to return
um whatever is at the last page of the
content
and I guess let's build on this a little
bit another useful function you know
obviously you want to start at the the
last page but let's say we're starting
to turn the page what might that look
like
right and so if we're turning the page
then all we want to do is increment the
last page right and so we might do
self.last page
and we just increment that by one
um and then we could call display page
after that
uh if we assume that
like we could if if we assume that these
two go together so if we assume that
when we turn the page we want to display
that page then I would just return
display page
yep
like that
um
and then actually I'm just going to go
ahead and code up this Library as well
so
this Library we have this collection of
books and then also the active book so
rather than initializing a library with
books I think let's just add them
um to this so initially
this collection might just be an empty
dictionary and then
the active book might be none right so
then
um when we
want to add stuff so add to collection
a book
what I'm going to do so
there's
either the user could
like or our API could like return a book
with the uh with the title and the
content
Etc but since we're we said that we
would pass the ID through like the
library because we might have like a
counter
like some sort of ID counter I mean this
is not the best way to do it but I think
this is like a a fine hack for right now
um
just to make all the ideas unique what
we can do here is
um
we can also when we want to add a book
just pass in the title and the content
and so then our new book
is going to be a book as we've defined
above with the ID
and
um the title and the count or the
content
and then after we create this new book
we want to
increment the ID counter
uh and then we also want to add this new
book Into The Collection right so I'm
going to add self.collection
um and
I'm going to make the ID whatever the ID
of the book is so actually I'm just
going to call new book dot ID because I
think that's a bit cleaner and this is
going to be the new book
and then we increment the counter by one
so this is us adding to the collection
um
so of course we want to remove from the
collection
and so we want we said that we wanted to
remove based on the ID so all we have to
do is I think
there's this
delete in Python
I'm not sure do you know keys
okay
is there a remove
I think that there's I mean it should
auto complete here in the coder pad oh
isn't it Dell isn't there a Dell
um
I mean I think the biggest thing is is
it going to be happening in place or is
it going to be happening and creating a
copy
um I I understand yeah so we want it in
place from The Collection I understand
what you're trying to do so the exact
details is is not super super important
to me
okay yeah so anyways this is removing
from The Collection
um and when we set active book
again we want to do this based on the ID
so I'm going to make self.active book
equal to whatever that ID is
uh and
let's see so the user has a library of
books they can add or remove from we did
that sending a book as active Okay and
then remembering where user left off so
we've actually taken care of that
already implicitly in our um book
uh class and then the reading
application only displays a page of text
at a time all right so then here we can
say Define display page
and actually we don't even need the the
ID of the book because we already have
the active book ID right and so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to go into my
collection
um and I'm gonna get the active book
like this so
yep
blah blah and I'm going to click or I'm
going to do dot display okay
and then of course we also have this
turn page that I could
um
to put up as well
yep
so you get the idea but
so we wanted oops
turn that page
um I do think that some like drawbacks
here are that
uh okay so one thing that we could have
done is instead of this active book
instead of saving the ID we could have
saved the book itself and I think from a
pythonic standpoint that might make
sense but then in the future if we're
using some sort of database or something
an ID would make more sense because
that's easier to store in like a table
um
and
if uh and okay also for this display
page you might see that we've called
this display page and turn page up here
in the book and the reason why I did
that rather than
um rather than just call like
self.book.content last page like book
dot last page or something
was because I think that like for
example this should be independent of
how we implement the book right so we
want to keep those as kind of block like
separate blocks as possible
and so here what this allows me to do is
when I go back to my book like if I
decide to scrap this implementation
Implement something else
I know that I would just have to
implement the methods display page and
turn page for that to work
um
and like these functions should work
this this looks good to me I like the
start I think that this uh definitely
lays out the foundation of what I was
looking for with the requirements of
this application so nice work with this
couple quick follow-up questions before
we kind of Branch into more of an
algorithms uh
type question as the follow-up here one
question is you know let's say you have
an older reader and their vision isn't
as great so they need to make this the
size of the font bigger so kind of
keeping that in mind that you might have
this variable font size how might you I
guess refactor or change or modify your
current structure and you don't have to
actually write code here let's just
discuss this to account for
um that increase in size
yeah
yeah so I so when we increase something
in size like I'm just thinking about
intuitively on our like phone screens or
something
um that type that tends to shift the
content right so like some page that
might hold a hundred words or a hundred
characters at you know
um a small font size might only hold 50
if when you double that font size
so uh for the book instead of having
this list what I might do is I might
just save the entire book as a string
and
um and based so I would let me just edit
this in here because I think it's easier
to visualize what I'm saying but so I
would might I might have like a font
size equal to
um
I guess we could just use like the
traditional like 12.5 or like yeah
whatever uh but
when we have this font size we could
come up with some sort of
um characters per page calculation
right and so that would be based off the
font size so calculate so this is going
to be pseudocode now this calculate
doesn't actually exist but calculate uh
based on that font size
um
and I'm commenting it out so it doesn't
have any errors but then uh when we do
calculate that then what we can do in
order to get our
um in order to get this display page
thing would be instead of indexing into
this content which is now
just a long string of characters
what we can do here is we can return
um we would have to do some sort of
calculation right so we would need to we
have this characters per page and we can
multiply that by whatever the last page
is
and
um so this would give us like kind of
the starting index of this long string
of characters to start uh
the content of that page
start index would be this
and then what we would want to do
is
um
what we want to do is then return the
self doc content from that start index
until the start index plus the number of
characters on that page
so that would be our end index so
actually let me just write that out to
make things a little bit more clear
so now essentially what I've done is we
have this variable font size which we
can calculate characters per page
depending on that font size so that
might be more characters or less
characters depending on how big the font
size is and then our content instead of
a list of strings is now just a really
long string of characters and I guess
some assumptions that I'm making here
are that uh this would just be
approximate so for example if we had a
backslash n which is like a line break
right that might just end up counting as
a character or two characters but the
assumption is that
um
that would be approximate per page or
maybe that we're using sort of some sort
of like mono spaced font or something
like that
um but essentially now that we have the
characters per page and then just a long
stream of characters that represents the
content we can index into that content
depending on like based on the last page
that we know and so what's really cool
here is that when we do Turn the Page uh
we can just end up calling this so this
is kind of that granularity that I was
talking about yeah that that makes a lot
of sense to me and definitely you see
the advantage of having that function
that you can change by having to
implement something different uh one
last quick I guess follow-up and then
we'll we'll move on to the algorithms
portion of this interview
um I'm just trying to think you know at
a high level let's say that we wanted we
had multiple users in this system and
they all
shared books so like you know they might
all share the Harry Potter books or
something like that like books are
common among all of them how might you
modify this yeah uh given that you know
some of these qualities of a book might
be shared between users because they're
all trying to access that same book
does that make sense
yeah so
um yeah yeah for sure so I I think that
when we start to you know have like
multiple people
um involved like this this these books
might get stored somewhere for example
in like a sequel table right and so then
when that happens we would still want to
maybe store like the ID the title the
content in that table now the only
changes would be that the these sort of
customizations are
um are per user but the book and the
content those are for this entire group
of people and what we can do I think is
um
is
instead of this ID counter being like
Library specific we can start
identifying books by their IDs on a more
like uh global scale right and so you
know this was kind of just a hack to
make this ID thing work and be
independent and be like unique but for
example when you put something into a
SQL table you can also have an ID
associated with those entries and so
maybe when we add to the collection if
we see that the title and the content is
already in the table then we instead
just return the book that's already in
that table or something like that yeah
okay I think that makes sense to me uh
cool I I'm yeah happy with this
discussion I think that we can move on
to the second portion I guess do you
have any I guess last questions on this
before I move on or last things you want
to say
um
yeah so no last questions I think that
the last thing I want to say is also
like it would really depend on like how
you implement this like group of people
right like so my immediate thought was
like a SQL table but that doesn't have
to be the only way
um
so yeah I think
okay cool I think it would depend on
that
um all right awesome uh let's yeah
switch gears and
I'm probably going to just comment this
out in case you do want to run some code
and there's any errors or issues in this
so I'm just going to comment this out
but I'm going to leave it here just so
we have it
to look back at and I'm going to just
indent this a bunch and we're going to
just start at the top of the screen
so don't mind all the stuff at the
bottom all right so another important
component of our book reading system
and this is completely independent you
don't have to reference any of your past
code is
I mentioned this is for short stories
and you could have independent Indie
authors you know adding these short
stories so they're not going to be you
know the classics not going to be those
types of titles they're probably smaller
authors so one thing that we want to
avoid in this system is plagiarism
so my task for you is to design an
algorithm that would be able to detect
the two most likely books that would
have plagiarism in them
it's like that the the two most likely
books that pop up as a match for
potential plagiarism uh in this in a
library
and we can Define as we can Define most
likely as meaning they have the longest
shared common section of text
so we're looking we have a library of
books and we're looking for the two that
have the longest shared common section
of text and we specifically might want
to know how many characters that
section of text is so you can imagine if
it's sharing a single word obviously not
an issue but if it's sharing six
paragraphs that's going to be a problem
so does that make sense
right so just to clarify some things
what Keith really means here by
substring is that for example if I have
a string such as learn
what are substrings of this well one
possible substring is learn
another possible is earn
because these are strings that are using
characters that belong to this string
learning
another possible one is earning
oops
now you might say Okay Kylie all of
these are consecutive in terms of the
characters so here all of these
correspond as characters that are next
to each other but in this specific
example Keith is not actually asking
okay it has to be a consecutive
substring instead what Keith is asking
is just any substring which means that
as long as the letters are in the
correct sequence you can skip characters
if you want to so for example here
leg would actually also be a substring
or
an so for example right here we have
earn as a substring of consecutive
characters but down here
I could rewrite it as a substring where
there's actually a gap of two characters
in the middle but this would still be a
valid substring so it doesn't have to be
consecutive we just need all the
characters to be in order from left to
right
let's see let's start off with kind of a
naive solution
for that
um
well
one thing that you could do is literally
come up with every single
combination of like substrings for both
of these
uh and then compare those and see which
two substrings are the longest right
um
but there's a lot of different
combinations for substrings and so I
think that we should come up with a more
elegant solution
um
let's see so
one thing
that I'm thinking is we should have
pointers that start at the beginning of
both yep strings and kind of move along
until one of them detects
a shared character
so
or like when until one of them takes
like the first shared character so here
actually like I would say the first
shared character is H right
um and so here we would have like
like the two pointers kind of be
this uh
maybe I'll go from the bottom
but here and
here
right and so we look at the next
character
and we realize okay they're not the same
so then we want to keep going
um but one
downside of this is that
well okay what if I want to start
comparing from here and here
right
okay and then I move it over and like
these two have like two shared
characters so I think that there's still
this question of there's a lot of
different combinations here
um
so
I think you're on the right track though
I like I like this and then okay so far
yeah
okay
um yeah so I know that here I want kind
of these pointers that are moving and
then I just want to be able to align
them right I think that's the that's the
key here is this alignment
and so now I think we just have to
figure out how to make that alignment
work
um
I'm kind of thinking like
like one thing that
we could do is kind of have more of a
base sentence and then one where when we
have
like
so for example if I
if I made this my base
sentence
then in the other sentence I would want
to search this sentence uh
for each character so
if I have the I here then like my first
I would start looking from here and then
maybe I would start to look from here
right but I think that that
would end up
also being kind of long because for
every single character in here you would
have to iterate through this entire
thing and do the whole matching process
um
and so I'm
does that make sense why that's like
maybe not the most optimal yeah that
makes sense
and I guess what would be the runtime of
that
uh it would be o of N squared because
well I guess if we have one sentence o
of N and one sentence o of M it would be
o of n m because for every single
character we'd have to run through the
other string
um M times and actually
okay so like if my base sentence is like
like what is the worst thing that can
happen is like a base sentence like this
right and then you're searching the
worst case example would be like
something like this right
where like if I have an i okay well I
have to go through each of these
and
so yeah I guess we would have to go
through until like they don't match
anymore but then that would just be the
very end of this
so like maybe I can add like an a at the
end of that
so then I would actually okay so that I
would say it would
it might be o of N squared M where n is
e yeah I think that makes sense to me I
think that we should come up with a
different solution I'm trying to think
of how dynamic programming word work
because I do think that this this might
be a dynamic programming problem
um
I'm not sure
of how to formulate it yes let's um I
think that you're on to something here
I think
I'm trying to think of a good ways to
kind of kick you off here
um
I mean I would say let's just lay out
let's assume that this is dynamic
programming uh I think as a good
starting point maybe we
can talk about sub problems here
and try to Define that and maybe that
will help us get to our solution or also
maybe just to find a base case and maybe
that will help us get to the solution so
I think
let's assume that dynamic programming
can be used here let's maybe just start
trying to figure out sub problems and
maybe a base case
yeah
yeah so I definitely think that the base
case would be pretty simple and it would
just be if there is a match right
between the two like if the two
sentences equal another that would be or
okay let's think about all the possible
base cases so
it'd be if there's a match
um or maybe we've iterated through
everything that we can and we're
comparing like an empty string to
non-empty or even empty to empty which
is when we would know that we're at the
very end right
yeah so for example with this match I
mean by like
um read to read like that would be an
exact match
so I I think the difficulty of this
problem is that
is that we can start anywhere in the
texts right
and
I guess if we were trying to recurse
through this
um
or if we if we were trying to go through
this with dynamic programming
what I would kind of want to do is
say
okay either like
like s is the start of some substring in
this sentence or it's not
right and if it's not then we want to
move over and we want to say okay well
then is like H is
um
a substring or the start of a substring
from this other sentence or it's not
and we want to kind of continue that
process
um and so if for example H is a
substring then we would want to figure
out what the longest
substring
longest matching one is and then that
would essentially like skip us over a
few yep a few uh blocks
and so I think another way to kind of
formulate this might actually be
like how many
how many characters can kind of almost
subtract
from the two
um
and I might uh I might jump in here just
I think you're on the right track but I
might provide a little bit maybe more of
a launching point just because I want to
be considerate of our our time here
um I think you're on the right track
I think that let's maybe try to Define
this like with a single line expression
like a single line recurrence type
expression
um because I think that if we can build
up to a you know build up sub problems
to that final state that will help us
so
let's say we have sections of text a
and I'll put this in uh CR with a is one
of our sections of text
and b is another one of our sections of
text
um
and basically that could be
uh hello world or something you know in
world
uh
just world or something like that
um we can assume that yeah basically
what we could start doing here is we can
imagine that we wanted to find the
longest match between a and b
and you could Define that as from
character index 0 to character index
0 here so like the longest common
subsequence here or substring of a b 0 0
would be our
kind of goal State because we would want
to find if we're working backwards let's
say we want to find all the way
to the beginning
but to help us get there
you know we could probably see if uh you
know what is the longest substring at
different indexes so if you know maybe
index three
index five so like this would be the I
guess last character five would be like
the last character of B
and I I guess keeping this in mind can
we Define this in such a way where we
maybe we can uh define an equation that
would help us work up to that final goal
which would be the entire
sequence
okay so if we're using kind of these a b
strings as example
um
let's define some like
like find
uh largest
substring or something
um
and we might have string a string B
right so
and you're saying okay let's do index a
and index b as well and start those off
with zero that would be our recurrence
relation and so
I guess what we'd want to do is find the
longest substring between
yep these
um and we want to increment yep one or
the other
yep
right
so like that
uh
or
or if
string a equals string B then what we'd
want to do is find the longest substring
um
we want to increment both of these
indices apparently oops sorry so I meant
string a at
index a and string B at index B like
this so then we'd want to increment both
of the indices and we want to add one
right because this means that we've
found a starting match
um
and what we'd want to do is actually
take the so here
um
and if you want to just write pseudocode
here it's fine too for me possibility
okay that makes sense to me
yeah so let's just do all these
possibilities and so then if the two
then we have this like third possibility
right
and what I would want to do is uh take
kind of the minimum
why is this giving me an error
oh so then I would want I would want to
return the max of
possibility one possibility two okay
let's write pseudo code
possibility one possibility to and then
possibility three only if it makes sense
to me if applicable
and
and then with our base case we said that
it would be if one of them is at the end
so let me add that in here
so maybe like if uh idx a is equal to
the length of string a then we want to
return zero
or or here or idxb is equal to the
length of string B
um
yeah so then for our longest substring
this makes sense now because
with each index we have the possibility
of Shifting it over one and trying to
compare this sentence with this entire
one
uh or
Shifting the other one over one
comparing those two
yep indices or those two substrings
from there on
or if they are a match then we also have
the third option of moving both of them
over so actually I should go from here
and then because uh this fine longest
substring repeats all that on the next
character for those two then we repeat
that process again and we add one every
single time to that
um
so I think logically this makes sense
now
one thing might also be that we start to
kind of uh recurse a lot on the same
indices right because we're trying all
these different combinations and if we
move them both over by one then
um
then we kind of are iterating overthrew
them a lot
so I think that one thing that we could
also do is Implement some sort of
memoization
so here
like maybe
hold on I lost the oh here we go okay so
then
like
if I
so if
the memorization is is none then we
might want to start this with some sort
of
uh it could be addiction I think that
also what could make sense is like a
list of lists
right
so like maybe negative one because
there's no such thing as a negative
one-length substring
um
and I'm gonna multiply that by the
length of like string a for example yep
and then this whole thing by the length
of string B
and so essentially I have this table of
[Music]
of
yeah
I always get confused with the direction
of these things but I understand the
goal of this length string a and length
string they basically create a table
that stores some of these values
yeah
exactly yeah yeah and then in order to
store that here then we would want to
create like the index a
index B I might be these might be
backwards but we would want to store
that essentially and so
um then we'd want to add a case of like
if
uh
if like this memo yeah
at index a index B these might be
backwards again if that's negative one
then we want to return or sorry if
that's not negative one then that means
that we've already found the answer so
then we just want to return whatever
memorize there
um and so at the very end we'd want to
just return memo
like that and
let me just think about these indices
quickly so uh the first one is string B
so actually if I just swap these two
that should make it work
uh because first we'd index in 2A and
then we'd index into B yep so yeah yeah
if I just swap those two that would work
cool um uh yeah this makes sense to me I
guess my last question I think that this
is the approach that I was uh uh kind of
thinking about as far as dynamic
programming goes my last question is
what would be the run time of this
um you know memoized uh dynamic
programming solution
um
okay so here we are going through all of
index a or all all string a and all of
string B right by incrementing these
indices until we hit a base case
so
so there's no way to avoid going through
both of them
um and and incrementing one but not the
other and so we essentially have to fill
out this entire memoization table in
order to figure out our answer right yep
which means that it would be a benefit
and then my last question I know we're
running right up on time is I guess
given the context of the original
problem was you might have a library of
books how would you leverage this find
commas longest substring to I guess find
the two most uh like the highest
probability matches in the entire uh
library of books
um I think that so here now that we have
this find the longest substring with
string a string B and we have all we
have so we let's suppose that we changed
uh
the implementation of this book to be
this like long string of characters for
the content then that means that what we
can do for this fine longest substring
is just pass in like
book a DOT content and book b dot
content and figure out the longest
substring between the two of them and we
can do that for all the combinations of
books
um unique combinations of books and
if we find for example
okay well so the prompt is to detect the
two most likely books that have
plagiarism so we would just return the
two books with the longest substring
but you know maybe we want to say like
any any books where more than 30 of the
care you know more than 30 of the book
is uh or maybe even like ten percent
um shares the same substrate and like we
might call that majorism uh that's all I
have thank you uh
for your time I guess quickly if you
have any questions I guess for me or any
questions about these prompts before I
uh head off
okay so note to the audience that in a
normal interview this would be a time
when I would dive deeper and ask
questions about
um you know Keith's work or what you
know he enjoys about the company
um and if I
you'll find something in one of his
answers that I'm really interested in
I'll dive into that a little bit more
but because this is just a fake
interview and I don't really have any
questions about Keith's company because
the company doesn't exist
um yep that makes sense to me and I I
did not give you any context really to
work with here so we don't have to
repeat what we did with uh the video
that posted on my channel but cool
that's where we can interview uh switch
gears
yeah all right so now let's switch over
to the feedback section uh session
um do you want to go through your notes
and kind of just share what was good
yeah it was bad your overall impression
I think this was an interesting session
because
I like wanted to squeeze as much as
possible into this like oftentimes you
might see like a smaller fully
object-oriented design or a smaller uh
only algorithms but I kind of wanted to
get both because ultimately from my
perspective as an interviewer like I
feel like having both Concepts is how I
actually evaluate your programming
skills because a single algorithm
doesn't tell me that much as far as
um your your actual talents and like if
you'd be a productive member of our team
and also the object-oriented design
might not say everything either so I
like the combination but it was a bit
like it is a lot of information so
feedback wise let's start with object
oriented design I think solid overall I
think that you hit like the key points
um
I think some of the things that I I'm
thinking about with regards to your
solution is
you hit all of like the key things that
I was looking for so like all books in
library remember active book remember
last page in all books display a page in
action book I think you did a good job
with like the basic class structure to
capture all of that I think what I would
have liked to see if I was to be like
nitpicky and and looking for even better
Solutions is I might look for even
further breakdown of classes so like I
think
um there was some things that could have
been broken down further where I think
maybe you could have a display class
even that could kind of separate the the
details like you have the book class
that has the title the content but then
the display class can handle like the
font sizes the characters per page all
that and just isolate that functionality
um yeah so that was like one thing that
I picked up on is just I think that it's
tricky in an interview setting but I
think that to isolate different
components and make it easier to fit all
together I think further breakdown of
these classes could have been beneficial
um and then my other kind of like
nitpicky comment in criticism would be
like I think
the the way that the IDS were structured
wasn't
um
necessarily like the the most easy to
understand
uh so I guess providing some more
details on
I guess adding robustness to these IDs I
think like one thing that would have
been interesting I guess it didn't ask
about this specifically but
um
the concept of like okay how could you
then maybe if you only had a title in
the the book contents how could you
maybe grab that ID retroactively or like
would you want to do that so like maybe
some more robustness in how the IDS were
set up
so that
uh you didn't have to have know the
system to necessarily get an ID
um does that make sense
yeah yeah for sure I definitely think
that the ID part was
one thing where it was yeah
like I would have rather just used the
title of the book or like some
combination of like the title and author
and I think like for example
um
at like an actual Library they have like
their code or whatever and they have
their system for you know if it's
fiction or whatever genre it is and then
like uh some combination of I think
author that
I don't really remember
um that they use to ID books and I think
that that probably would have been like
a better solution is if we had like the
title and author and yeah it is tricky
because you don't have access to that
nice Library I think the key thing that
you did well with the IDS is that you
knew that had to be unique you didn't
want to have collisions and by
mentioning like titles might have
collisions that's super important
because that would cause all sorts of
headaches for us
um let me see what else I wrote down I
mean again like I'll reiterate like this
was a good solution this was a solid
solution this would be like something
I'm looking for so like my feedback is
more nitpicky and like how could things
be improved further I think another way
and this is kind of similar to breaking
things out from you know a book class
and then a display class to actually put
that onto our Kindle Cloud Reader but I
think another way you could have maybe
broke this down in a logical manner was
when I asked that last follow-up
question which was basically
you know you might have many users in
this and now we need to be able to each
user needs to have their own like last
page for each book and all that
I think that your answer could have been
a bit more
nuanced there
I think one thing that you could have
maybe mentioned is
we could have potentially used like
super classic subclassing to maybe have
like you know a base book class but
maybe there was like a user book class
that built off of
that class book that you know everyone
shared ID everyone shared title everyone
shared content but all those user
specific things could have reused some
of that previous code but built off of
it so that would have been an
interesting idea too
yeah yeah
that's all I have for the yeah object
oriented
um portion uh any I guess other comments
on that section
cool and then I think for algorithm
solution
um I think throughout the interview you
did a good job of explaining your
thoughts super super important to anyone
listening to this uh don't just write
something down
talk through what you're writing down as
you're writing it that helps me make
sure that I know what you're talking
about that makes sure that I know that
you're on the right track or off track
so you did a good job both in the
object-oriented design as well as the
algorithm just explaining what you are
thinking and the pros and cons so like
one thing I liked in the algorithm
section is
you know coming up with a very naive
solution to start I like seeing that
kind of iterative approach see that
you're kind of working towards more
Optimal Solutions so I liked the idea of
using like every single substring and
these two but then realizing this is not
optimal I liked then you're kind of
building and taking that and being like
okay maybe that's not the best approach
but let's take a base sentence and a you
know a new sentence
and
uh you know start going character by
character in the base sentence and
compare it to the you know comparison
sentence I think that that was you know
a you know you're working towards a
better solution it's going to be better
than that every substring approach but
still not quite optimal and kind of
realizing that there was more
improvements that could be made there
was a challenge in how to get to the
dynamic programming solution I think we
maybe lost some of those details you
would normally have included on like the
Nuance of this and how you might
improve it so like I would have also
liked to hear mention not only of herb
tense but also like punctuation if we
have to you know keep that in mind so if
someone changed periods exclamation
points should those still match or
should they not match
all of that
um and then just kind of getting to the
dynamic programming uh I think this was
definitely like a challenge trying to
figure out how to formulate this so I
definitely had to help a bit more I
think in an optimal like perfect run
through uh you would have had
you've gotten a little bit further
without me having to prod but I think
the nature of dynamic programming is
unless you're reviewing it and like
really like studying it and staying on
top of it like in the real world you
don't have to know this type of stuff uh
you're not coming up and like designing
from scratch dynamic programming you're
usually looking at notes and all that so
like I was you know I'm okay in an
interview setting having to prod a bit
uh but you know that's I guess the
difference between a good interview and
a perfect interview is like the nature
is I had to provide a decent amount of
details and kind of help you get to a
recurrence and then once I gave you that
starting point the launching point of
the recurrence uh you did a great job
running with it that was definitely like
the optimal longest common subsequence
or substring type solution with
recursion and memoization to help get us
to the optimal so it was nice to see
that once you had an idea of what we
needed to do
that your Rams will run with it and knew
exactly you know where you could
Implement an optimal solution
I think that's all I have I'm rambling
on a bit but hopefully those notes make
sense and I think we can further discuss
yeah I definitely think think that this
longest substring was a slightly more
challenging problem based on like
um you know the problems I've done on
the code or like the ones that I faced
in like actual coding interviews
um but that's not to say that it's not
like
a good problem right I think it's a
really good problem to ask and to kind
of figure out
um you know what are my strengths and
weaknesses and I think that one thing
that
you know you've probably learned from
this is that okay you know maybe I have
certain ideas that are there and I like
needed a little push in trying to
formulate it properly but then once you
gave me just like a structure to
formulate it then I was able to take
that and be able to uh run with it right
which I think that
you know from an interviewer's
standpoint like when you're interviewing
it's not just about can they do it or
not it's also about how would they you
know how would what would an interaction
with this person look like right and so
actually one thing that I really liked
about this was that it it seemed to be
pretty collaborative and it seemed to be
very casual rather than like me taking a
test
um and so
you know what that tells me as somebody
interviewing is oh yeah like if I do get
stuck like this person would be able to
give me a hint and then I would be able
to take that hint and do the rest of the
problem
um
so yeah I mean I do wish that I was able
to just get that in formulated but I
think that also dynamic programming is
typically tricky like that and it takes
a lot of it just takes practice kind of
to yeah and I think that you make a good
point where it's like this was
definitely the dynamic programming
question was a hard question uh and I
think sometimes once you feel like
you're off track and an interviewer like
oh shoot I don't know the answer to this
like I'm screwed I think realize that
you might be purposely given a hard
question because then you can identify a
larger range of candidates so like you
know maybe the tippy top is like it's
it's instinctual for them to like
realize how to solve this with dynamic
programming but I'd say like the strong
half of this they won't know it right
away but they'll be able to work
themselves to it so like don't get too
flustered this is not to you this is to
a general comment to anyone listening
don't get too flustered by like getting
stuck you're oftentimes expected to get
stuck uh you're human so you're going to
get stuck it's how you rebound it and I
think you did a good job mentioning you
know you rebounded well and and that's
what's important still like a very
strong interview because you were able
to work to the solution and it was a
hard problem
yeah I will also mention I think one
other thing that a lot of interviewers
do tend to look for is probably testing
so I do think that
um yeah you know it's a good it's a good
signal you know we were running out of
time but I think
um
for both the for the interviewer it's a
good signal if the interviewee brings up
testing and says oh like you know I like
the solution but in order to verify my
answer I would like to test it or I'd
like to run it or something like that
um and I think with in terms of
what the interviewer is looking for is
that they want you they want to see that
you're going to be a good software
engineer right and I think testing is a
big part of that equation and so I think
that
um
I think that just mentioning maybe hey
like these are a few cases that I would
have ran through if I had extra time or
you know here are some of the edge cases
like I think this might work for most
cases but there might be some sort of
edge case here and there that I should
have like gone through
um I think those would be yeah that's a
great that that should also be a
component that
testing is super important so seeing
that and it is challenging because we
did kind of run out of time so like I
feel like you didn't hit some of those
things that you probably would have hit
if we had all the time in the world one
thing that's interesting I saw this on
Twitter or LinkedIn as an idea I don't
know what your thoughts are on it I
think that it's a pretty solid idea I
would kind of be impressed if a
candidate did this
but I could see it going either way is
the someone mentioned they were like a a
um data analyst at Google
and in the interview process like they
screwed up I think a couple queries a
SQL queries and after the interview they
like
you know calm down like they collected
their thoughts and they like emailed the
interview interviewee interviewer like
the solutions like oh like I goofed up
there this is how I would have solved it
if I you know had a little bit more time
they followed up with like some
solutions so it'd be interesting I don't
know if you think it would be a good
idea or a bad idea I could see it going
over either way but to like follow up
and be like oh I didn't get a mention
these testing cases this is what I would
have done uh I think it's probably
situation specific because
it could be kind of weird too I don't
know I'm just throwing that out there as
an interesting Avenue if you feel like
you
wanted to redeem a bad interview or
something like that and like have some
Saving Grace
yeah well I definitely I definitely do
think that that is
like I don't think it's necessarily I
don't think it would be a bad idea under
any circumstance I think that okay maybe
your interviewer would never see that
and they find it a little bit strange or
maybe they've already submitted there
whatever but I don't think it can hurt
um and if anything I think it shows
dedication and it shows that you know
you couldn't solve this problem
but you took time and you thought about
it some more and you didn't give up and
then you did come up with the right
solution and you followed up and
communicated that yeah
I think it yeah it's situation depended
if I feel like my interview went great I
probably wouldn't need feel like the
need to do that but if I feel like oh
shoot that was like I was I'm so much
better than that
at that point it can't hurt to do
something like that and just keep it
casual keep it like yeah hey I thought
of this thanks again for your time yeah
uh take care like uh
okay so now after the interview I just
wanted to follow up with you guys that
interview if I walked away from it I
would have been like all right well
there are certain aspects that you know
just like Keith said there are certain
aspects that
signaled you know I was probably a
strong candidate but I personally would
have walked away from that being like
dang there are some parts that I
probably could have done better on like
I needed his help a little bit I
probably could have you know eventually
gotten if I just had a bit more time to
think or maybe today was just not my day
and that's just sometimes how these
interviews go you can't do perfectly on
all of them now a few notes about my
implementation specifically I use
pseudocode because Keith the interviewer
specifically said it was okay too and in
this specific problem I really wanted to
focus on the algorithm and not really
kind of get
uh you know get into the syntax of
things and so for me uh python is almost
basically pseudocode so most of it was
very pythonic
um but I come to doll out because I was
too lazy to get that Max part working
because I wrote like possibility three
if applicable and I was just a little
bit too lazy to like actually
yeah Implement that and then also there
was some underlining that just wouldn't
go away and that was really bothering me
so that's why I also just turned it to
uh an entire comment
now some things to remember about
interviewing in general so don't be
scared to ask questions turn the
interview more into a conversation
because that also gives the interviewer
a signal of this is what I'm like as a
teammate this is what it's going to feel
like when you're working with me
now during the interview I would always
recommend repeating the question to the
interviewer just so that uh you can
check if you actually understood the
question and then from there maybe even
ask clarifying questions
um and I typically start with something
known as the naive solution which is
this this is the first thing that I
thought of and this solution would work
but it's kind of this uh very Brute
Force solution where it might take a lot
of time and it might not work you know
in my time out for these super long
strings or these super long data files
or this very large array or something
like that so it's very very unoptimal
but you know it is a solution
and then from there that's when I start
brainstorming okay well this sucks in
terms of timing so let's figure out how
we can optimize it so that we can make
it run faster and from there if you can
find the optimal solution then you
implement it the best way and you are
good to go
all right thank you guys for watching
today uh best of luck if any of you have
software interviews coming up you know
be confident